à bien bien très bien
je vois que vous y avez pensé vous
l'amenez avait amené avec vous votre
cerveau utilise un cerveau très utile
pour écouter un neurologue
vous parlez de cerveau pour voir un
neurologue bouger son cerveau pour
toucher 1 en ânonnant pas touchés c'est
que je suis chatouilleux donc très bien
pour le cerveau car avec votre cerveau
vous avez amené votre curiosité ce
formidable détecteur de nouveautés ce
mobilisateur de toute votre attention
nous très bien le coup du cerveau mais
mais par contre à nous ont pas lui me
dites pas que vous l'avez amené qui
votre corps vous avez bien cet
encombrant celui qui pendant que je vous
parle va manifester son impatience son à
tranquillité et que je frotte le visage
et que je croise et décroise les jambes
et que je tousse haute pour éclaircir la
gorge et que je renifle aux plus graves
un fou rire qui monte qui gagne une
envie de faire pipi qui presse ou un
éternuement qui picote le bout du nez et
votre cerveau nono nombre alors
j'appelle ça des petits tracas du
quotidien
et je précise des petits tracas
neurologiques
pourquoi des petits tracas parce qu'on
croit que nous serions tellement mieux
sans eux sans ces moments où le corps
d'autres corps se rappelle à notre bon
souvenir
et pourquoi neurologique parce que c'est
dans votre cerveau que ça se passe dans
le corps qui est dans votre cerveau
votre corps votre cerveau à la fois une
seule et même chose vous et c'est de ça
que je veux parler
alors comment vous faire ressentir que
toutes ses sensations
ces informations qui vous gagne à
travers le corps sont autant de
dispositions de sollicitations pour agir
de pression pour l'action et toutes ces
sollicitations le lobe frontal va faire
le choix à faire le tri quoi faire nous
sommes assaillis de sollicitations de
pression pour agir et le lobe frontal
comme je l'expliquais à des enfants de
maternelle je faisais une
mini-conférence et quelques semaines
dans une maternelle et aux enfants leur
expliquer le lobe frontal c'est celui
qui donne la permission donné la
permission pour des gamins de 4 5 ans ça
parle ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est le moment où l'adulte dit à
l'enfant vas-y tu peux y aller et pour
les adultes que nous sommes donné la
permission ça veut dire aussi quelque
chose ça veut dire que cette permission
de plus souvent qu'avant là bas alors je
vais essayer de vous faire éprouver ça
en vous soumettant un petit test
neuro-psychologique très simple très
classique en neuropsychologie s'appelle
le go nogo givet go j'y vais pas no go
la consigne est simple quand je vais
claquer des mains vous aller claquer des
mains immédiatement
donc je claque des mains donc accéder
mais si je tape deux fois dans les mains
vous ne tapez pas est-ce que vous êtes
prêts
allons-y très bien c'est pas facile vous
sentez votre corps qui dit je veux ta p
quand vous me voyez taper deux fois dans
mes mains toute la partie postérieure de
votre cerveau dire oui nous on aime
taper on va taper on va taper et votre
lobe frontal qui dit non tapez on n'a
pas la permission et c'est de ça que je
veux parler
c'est à dire que les sensations gênante
les sensations corporelles gênante
ces petits tracas dont je parle et ça
fonctionne comme ça c'est l'impression
qu'elle donne que le corps veut imposer
sa volonté aux souhaits de notre esprit
comme s'il y avait un bras de fer entre
le corps et le cerveau
alors je vais prendre un exemple qui va
parler à tout le monde la chatouille la
chatouille c'est le rire qui monte en
réponse à une stimulation de zones très
particulière du corps une stimulation
une sensation un comportement le rire le
rire au camp à son corps défendant comme
on dit mais on devrait dire à son
cerveau défendant alors si ce qui
contrariait plutarque le philosophe de
la rome antique qui trouvait désolant
que les esprits les plus sérieux puisse
être asservi par la chatouille il trouvé
cela contraire à ses préceptes de bonne
santé ce que regrettait le philosophe
c'est que le corps puisse dicter sa loi
à l'esprit mais est ce qu'on peut
vraiment séparer le corps et le cerveau
qui sait qu'on a chatouillé que se
passe-t-il stimulation d'abord ou pas
n'importe où pas dans les zones les plus
sensibles
si on regarde le mucus de pennfield
c'est à dire
cette représentation déformée du corps
proportionnée à la densité de récepteurs
qu'on a sous la peau c'est à dire aussi
à la quantité de neurones qui dans le
cerveau vont traiter cette information
sensitive est ce que vous le voyez deux
grandes échelles
est ce que vous les voyez un coup xxl
non bien sûr
parce qu'en fait les zones chatouilleuse
ne sont pas les plus sensibles ce sont
des zones qui sont surtout remarquable
parce qu'elles sont vulnérables
vulnérables parce que par exemple ici
recul des gros vaisseaux la carotide
l'artère axillaires qui irrigue tout le
bras et nous gardons ces zones plutôt
contre nous ou si nous étions des
animaux plutôt sous le vent il n'y a pas
de protection d'où ce côté vulnérable et
ce risque qu'il ya à laisser à 0 chez
les approcher partie parce que la
chatouille c'est sociale il faut être
deux pour une chatouille un chatouilleur
il fait tout y est
si elle vous chatouiller tout seul rien
ne se passera rien pourquoi parce que
vous ne menacer personne en glissant vos
propres doigts sous vos aisselles et
parce que la surprise disparaît parce
que votre cerveau peut prédire
exactement où se fera le contact pas de
risque pas de surprise aucune émotion ce
que la chatouille va activer dans le
cerveau c'est le corps émotionnel un
carrefour d'information où se mélangent
la sensation physique les émotions donc
et puis tout ce qui s'élabore pas la
pensée à propos de la situation
la cognition et ce carrefour dans le
cerveau il est là c'est l'insula le lob
de l'insula une région assez peu connu
par le grand public est une région qui
elle aussi est profondément enfouies au
niveau du cortex
mais au fond d'un pli et cette région
elle intègre les informations des
sensations corporelles des émotions et
de la cognition
alors passons à notre exemple après la
chatouille la gratouille que se
passe-t-il si on soumet des volontaires
dans une imagerie une irm qui réalise
des images du cerveau en train de
fonctionner à des vidéos qui vont
regarder de gens qui se grattent des
gens qui se grattent ils vont avoir très
vite une sensation de démangeaison et un
besoin de se gratter et dans leur
cerveau que démontrent les images là
aussi une activation de l'insula dès que
la sensation émergent
l'action pointe le bout de son nez
sensation actions si le lobe frontal de
notre permission ou le bâillement sa
nage est ce que ça vous gagne
l' envie de bâiller un message parce que
c'est un message qui devient une
sensation puis un besoin puis un
comportement et enfin un signal
qu'est-ce que je suis fatigué l'impact
sur le corps la potentialité des actions
et le lobe frontal qui fait le tri alors
pourquoi est ce que je me penche sur ce
qu'est ce qui se passe dans nos cerveaux
lorsque surgissent ces petits tracas
pourquoi sont ils des prétextes à
m'intéresser aux relations entre corps
et cerveau parce que je crois que nous
avons tort de penser que nous avons un
corps comme si nous n'étions que le
cerveau et que ce cerveau avait en
charge un corps c'est encombrant
non nous n'avons pas encore nous sommes
score
alors pourquoi cette illusion si tenace
d'un esprit c'est pareil que la
chatouille ne devrait pas venir
bousculer
d'où vient-elle cette illusion
je voudrais faire une hypothèse
cette hypothèse se base sur un constat
nous vivons de plus en plus entouré de
ses dispositifs de traitement de
l'information
ce sont des outils très précieux qui que
nous ressentons de plus en plus comme
indispensable et nous sommes familiers
de cette intelligence qu'on appelle
virtuel ou artificiels et cette
fréquentation quotidienne pourrait avoir
selon moi de conséquence une conséquence
analogique est une pratique
l'analogie c'est que nous nous voyons
nous mêmes comme un équivalent de ce
système de traitement de l'information
l'analogie envahit même notre discours
dans le langage courant nous disons j'ai
buggé où je fasse une mise à jour de mes
connaissances nous nous voyons comme une
intelligence certes pas artificiel mais
déconnecté de tout support est la
conséquence pratique c'est que nous
passons de plus en plus de temps
connecté à travers ces écrans et dans
ces moments où nous sommes connectés
nous n'écoutons pas ce qui se passe
notre corps nous sommes coupés des
sensations nous avons tort nous trompons
nous pourvoyons nous sommes d'abord des
corps et ça l'évolution nous l'apprend
depuis la cellule primitive l'évolution
la complexification des organismes qui
finalement se sont dotées d'un système
nerveux et enfin l'émergence de la
pensée de la conscience très tardive
nous sommes d'abord des corps et la
pensée s'élabore ensuite et vient créer
un récit qui puisse nous convenir alors
réconcilier le corps et le cerveau comme
médecin comme neurologue je vois de plus
en plus de patients que ces sensations
physiques alarme qui sont débordés par l
qui ne les comprennent plus alors que ce
sont surtout des manifestations de
l'anxiété de l' angoisse
une étude américaine il ya quelques
années avait montré que si on suit une
population saine de 1000 personnes
pendant un mois
800 vous ressentir des symptômes et sur
ces 800 plus de 300 vont penser aller
voir un médecin pour ça et au final huit
sont hospitalisés
la vie normale du corps c'est de sentir
des choses nous ne pouvons pas le
sensation alors comment restaurer cette
unité corps et cerveau en pratiquant
score en bombardant le cerveau de
sensations en l'exposant à des
expériences physiques en structurant
cette plaie béante
cette coupure que je vois entre l'esprit
et le corps comment par exemple
simplement marcher marcher en imposant
ses sensations musculaires tendineuses
articulaires c'est l'impression
respiratoires cardiaques en étant
attentif vigilant le vent sur la peau
les bienfaits de la marche sont
inépuisables
un philosophe situationniste raoul
vaneigem a écrit dans son dernier livre
une phrase que j'aime beaucoup le togo
mme selon lequel l'esprit domine le
corps instaure le triomphe de la pensée
séparé et fonde une civilisation où
l'homme est comme exilé de lui même non
nous ne sommes pas des software embarqué
sur des roulettes
nous sommes des corps d'abord décor
alors vivons avec
merci
[Applaudissements]